oh it's not a costume i'm an elf well
technically i'm a human but i was raised
by elves your christmas season
probably started just like ours did
cozying up
[Applause]
and putting on our favorite christmas
classic elf
but we just learned something about this
holiday movie that totally blew our
minds
we always knew that elf was a special
kind of christmas movie
but we had no idea that almost all of it
was
real that's right one of the most
delightful classics of all time was made
like
almost no movies are and the behind the
scenes secrets will make your head spin
even more than 30 turns around a
revolving door
every day on set i thought you were way
too over the top
elf has cemented itself in our hearts as
one of the most beloved christmas movies
of all time
even though it's not even 20 years old
and while it might seem like this
perfectly heartwarming holiday hit was
destined to become a classic
it actually had some real trouble
getting off the ground and could have
been a very different movie if the
producers had gotten their way
for starters the studio originally
wanted a different saturday night live
comedian to star in the titular role
and that actor was none other than chris
farley
we'll be in touch the writer of the film
wasn't happy with that idea
so he actually turned them down and
waited over a year for another producer
to come on board
who had the absolutely perfect idea the
up-and-coming
saturday night live superstar will
ferrell trust me
they like you the sweater worked and
even though we know that farrell is the
perfect person to embody the childlike
wonder of buddy the elf
the rest of the world was not convinced
he had the chops to pull it off
fortunately the team were able to
convince them that he was the man for
the job
and his casting was official do it yeah
more hip
more hip god it might have helped that
they had piqued the interest of one of
the most successful directors in all of
hollywood
john favreau except wait a second
favreau only had one directing credit to
his name at the time
and the producers weren't sure about him
either it was only when they brought him
in to talk about the film that he was
able to prove that he knew
exactly how to bring elf to the big
screen in a way that lined up with
exactly the kind of movie that the
writer and producers wanted to make
so they had a director and a star it was
time to get elf
off the ground and it was john favreau's
direction that
really made elf the movie it is today
because without him
another director might have decided to
use a ton of digital effects
in order to pull off all of the north
pole scenes but when he first
entered the meeting he had three rules
that he wanted to follow
make elf look like a stop motion rank
and bass christmas special
make it a truly family christmas movie
and make it a timeless
classic in order for it to be timeless
they couldn't use any cgi
at all because favreau knew that in 10
years time the animation would look
outdated and old-fashioned
which is exactly why there's nothing
fake about elf
every single thing you see in the movie
is done for real and some is even more
real than we could have imagined
a lot of people down south don't believe
in santa claus what
because will ferrell and john favreau
had not yet become the massive
celebrities they are today
when it came to shooting all of the
scenes of buddy running around the
streets of manhattan for the first time
they could actually just go out onto the
street and run around
so the first thing we shot was the
lincoln tunnel
i was terrified for will nowadays will
ferrell
wouldn't have been able to go two feet
in an elf costume without getting mobbed
by
fans but back then they had a ton of
freedom
so they put him in costume grabbed a
cameraman and hit the bustling new york
city streets
which means that all of the people that
buddy interacts with
and all of the crowds who are just
trying to get where they're going
are actually real people and not paid
extras
those are real people those aren't
actors the most amazing of which is the
man in the red jogging outfit who just
happens to look
exactly like santa he wasn't placed into
that costume by the wardrobe people
the guy in the red jogging suit santa
sit
that guy was just there and luckily they
had one of the best improvisers in the
world playing buddy
who knew exactly how to jump into these
spontaneous situations and create those
whimsical and hilarious moments
but not all of the real aspects of
making elf were all fun
and games with nyc strangers in fact
once the time came to shoot all of the
scenes that take place in the north pole
things got a whole lot more complicated
see because they couldn't use the
computer graphics in order to shrink the
elves or make buddy look like a giant
they were presented with the unique
challenge of trying to figure out how to
do it all
on set and by set we do mean a giant
hockey arena in vancouver canada
and not the actual north pole you sit on
a throne of lies
they started by building sets that were
abominably tiny
so that the already tall will ferrell
would look larger than life when walking
around on them
it's much cheaper to shoot on stages in
canada and then they brought out a piece
of old hollywood movie magic
called forced perspective that no one
had used in decades
in scenes between buddy and the other
elves they would actually put farrell
a lot closer to the camera than the
other actors with sometimes up to 10
feet of distance between them
that way when you look at it through the
camera it appears as if buddy is
huge and the elves are tiny when really
they're just far away
it was like you were reinventing the
wheel things got even trickier when it
came to the part where buddy sits on
papa elf's lap
in order to make it look good on camera
they actually had feral
sit on a little stool that was placed
above a real-life child
who was lying down on a diving board the
actor who played papa elf
bob newhart was sitting on a chair 10
feet away in the background
now that is some serious movie magic
i think we ended up with 47 course
perspective setups which is
a tremendous amount the other very
important part of the world of elf
is definitely the influence of the
old-timey rank-and-bass stop-motion tv
episodes
especially the very famous rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer episode
i'll find homes for all those misfit
toys
john favreau wanted the north pole to
look exactly like that world
and he insisted that they include a
handful of real stop-motion sequences
which cost
a lot more and take up way more time
luckily they were able to get it all
done on time
and there is no doubt about it that the
stop-motion world of the north pole is
one of the most beloved parts of the
entire movie
why did you do that one about the elf
there are a few things about elf that we
aren't quite sure if are real or not
and the biggest one has got to be when
buddy pours maple syrup all over his
spaghetti while we may never know if
that
is actually will ferrell eating a pile
of tomato sauce with syrup on it
it is something we could see him doing
for real one thing we do know however
is that the gum that he pulls off of the
new york city fence and puts in his
mouth was
definitely placed there by the
production and not a feat of the bravest
and grossest
method acting that even jared leto might
cringe at the stunt where buddy tries to
put the star on top of the tree by
running full speed at it before
both he and the tree come crashing down
however that was all real
and done in one take they used something
called a texas switch
in which farrell walked just off camera
long enough for his stent devil to come
back
running in and take a flying leap at the
tree with total abandon
we love all of these behind the scenes
secrets from the making of this iconic
movie
it just makes watching it again all the
more amazing when you know
exactly how much hard work and ingenuity
went into the whole thing
and john favreau was right if they had
done what everyone in hollywood
does these days and just let cgi take
care of it
it wouldn't have retained all of its
christmas magic and would probably look
super outdated already thanks to the
amazing
team and favro's three rules for making
elf it can now stand the test of time
and continue to be one of the best
christmas movies ever
i wanted to make a movie that had the
potential to be a a classic that would
show every year
just when we thought we couldn't love
elf any more than we already do
learning all about just how much love
was put into the making of it
somehow makes the movie even more
heartwarming what about you
are you an elf fan or do you have
another all-time favorite holiday
classic
is there anything we missed about elf
that we just have to know about
let us know in the comments and don't
forget to subscribe to keep up with all
the latest videos from the things
you